Dr Zakia um are there any particular
activities a Muslim should concentrate
upon during this blessed month of
Ramadan and of course we should relate
to you the importance of the fact that
our viewers really can gain massive
benefit by knowing
specific activities they can get
involved in and they can start planning
the Ramadan now yes I believe that this
is a very good question because most of
the activities will'll be dealing as
time goes on in the episode but just to
give a brief outline I will just specify
a few important because the whole answer
will take very long the few important
point that will be noted is that number
one it is the Nia the Nia is very
important the Nia of fasting should only
be for Allah subhana wa tala and for a
fasting to be accepted the is important
so making the is very important without
which the fasting will not be accepted
number two is observing the Sunnah of
the
fast that we'll be dealing in detail in
the next few days but just a point to be
noted that one of the important Sunnah
is that we should
have as late as possible that is just
before the break of dawn just before F
Salah and we should break our fast have
as early as possible immediately after
Sunset furthermore in this blessed month
we should be careful and
we should avoid all things which are
prohibited which are Haram and all
things which are makr and this is the
best opportunity where a person if he
has certain activities which are against
the Sharia whether they doing Haram
activities or mro activities this is the
best time he can abstain from it and
that will be a good habit which
inshallah he may abstain maybe
throughout his life for example if a
person is habituated to drinking alcohol
if he can abstain from having alcohol
from the break of dawn to Sunset he can
abstain from it from the kle to the
Grave similarly we should take care that
we should abstain from the things which
are
Mak for example it is Mak to stand and
drink water and if you Hab to that so
see to it that in this month of Ramadan
while having water we should sit down
this for the sun of the prophet so it's
a good month in which you can abstain
from the Haram activities which you have
been doing maybe some of them or the Mak
activities
furthermore it's a good time where you
can Implement many of the Sunnah of the
prophet in your day-to-day life for
example maybe sporting a
beard many Muslims don't have a beard so
it's a good month where you can follow
the Sunnah of the
Prophet the Sunnah of the Prophet about
the duas of when you enter the home when
you leave the toilet the Dua that is
there when you're traveling in a vehicle
sub so this is a good month in which you
can adopt as much as as possible so that
we can be on the straight path this is a
very good month where you should see to
it that you should offer the Salah not
only the five time Salah which is a f
even try and offer as many Na and
Sunnah and if you're not habituated to
reading in congregation see to that read
in congregation and as first possible go
to the mosque for the
Salah in this month we should be
particular that we do not miss the T
many people think and it is a fact that
it is a Sunnah but many people think
that because it's a Sunnah we can Miss T
T is a very important sunah though it's
not a f but every Muslim should make it
a point that as far as possible they
should attend T because of the blessings
it has so T is very important which
Muslim should never
miss and when we offer T many of us we
rush through T because we want to
complete the Quran and many of them read
the T 100 miles per hour we should read
the Tavi with patience at a moderate
pace so that people can understand what
is the Commandment of Allah subhana
tala and
that if time permits and if possible we
should try and do in the last 10 days
and while doinga make it a point that we
don't socialize many people make a
mistake of socializing during the whole
purpose of is
defeated furthermore we should do more
Dua in this month we should do more
supplications this is the month of
Dua and we should do more Z spend time
in Remembering Allah subhana wa tala and
also worshiping him
this is the month in which we should try
and read as much as Quran as possible
besides reciting the Quran Arabic if you
know Arabic as a language then there's
no problem but if you don't know then
also read the translation of the Quran
in the language we understand the best
if you understand English read in
English if you understand Udu read in
Udu read it in the language you
understand the best but while resting
the Quran for which you'll get a Saab
also read the translation of the Quran
so that you can Implement on the
guidance of Allah subhana wa tala if
possible read the Quran once in every
seven days or at least
read one J every day so that you
complete the Quran at least once in the
full month of Ramadan in this month try
and read as much as Hadith that possible
but see to it that you read the
authentic
Hadith and the best book on Hadith is
the book
ofari
then is say Muslim you can read the
other also but read authentic books on
read books on the lifestyle and the SE
of the Prophet Muhammad Salli
wasallam see to it that if you have not
given the zakat please give the zakat
which is an obligatory
charity and every rich person who has a
saving of more than the nisab level more
than 85 Gams of gold he or she should
give
2.5% of his saving every Lun in charity
that is zakat and many people they do
not calculate the zakat properly you
make it a point that you calculate the
zakat honestly and it is better to give
little bit more rather than to give less
so calculate it properly and see to it
that you give your zakat and this
Ramadan is a month of generosity it's a
month of s and you get 10 times more
reward for good deeds so this is the
month where you should do maximum
charity and besides that we should make
it a point that during this month we
should be cheerful many of the Muslims
they look dull they look gloomy you
should be cheerful and
happy and we should give more time to
our family many times we neglect our
family which is CED that we give more
time to our family and do all these
activities
collectively we should also have H to
the people around you that means we
should deal with the other human
beings with Mercy with love with care if
they've done some mistakes they forgive
them this is the month of forgiveness if
you have done something wrong to them
for
forgiveness live with the people around
you with love care and with
affection we should to that means
Ponder on the things see to it that you
plan your month of
Ramadan plan it properly and see to it
that you do not waste not even a minute
not even a second this is the month of
gaining and this month is the best month
for self-improvement
also and besides that should also make
it a point to do
islah with your other Muslim brothers
and
sisters it's also the best month to do
dawa that is convey The Message of Islam
to the
non-muslims so it's my request to the
brothers and sisters that plan your
month efficiently and see to it that you
utilize every second of this bless
month